Oh, schauen wir mal jetzt.
Jetzt müsste es ja eigentlich...
Also jetzt habe ich neu gestartet.
Mehr kann ich jetzt beim besten Willen nicht machen.
So, mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist.
Passt.
Jetzt okay.
Passt das Sound jetzt?
Passt.
Okay, gut.
Okay, was auch immer das Teil für ein Problem hatte.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber dann, machen wir weiter.
So, Sam Fischer, kannst du mich wieder entweiten?
Hallo, moin. Moin, Leute.
Ich streame schon.
Ihr habt jetzt gerade erst die Benachrichtigung gekriegt.
Aber ich streame schon eine ganze Weile.
Plus, mein Sound war gerade nicht synchron.
Deswegen habe ich den Stream neu gestartet.
Provider, Telekom und Unity Media.
Gerade über Telekom.
Eichenwald.
Es gibt ja ein paar englischsprachige Caster,
die schaffen es mittlerweile, Eichenwald, Eichenwald,
auszusprechen.
Wobei, das hört ich dann eher so an wie Eichenwald.
Eichenwald.
Aber die kriegen es hin.
Na, dass ich zwei Provider habe, hat historische Gründe.
Vielleicht zwei Provider, aber das soll es.
Ich hatte die ganze Zeit Unity Media.
Weil es bei mir nur DSL 16.000 gegeben hat.
Und jetzt hat die Telekom ausgebaut.
Und jetzt gibt es VDSL 100.
Dann habe ich mir VDSL 100 geholt.
Aber Unity Media läuft noch.
Ähm, ja, Sandro, das war mal.
Da habe ich quasi dann über Telekom,
also ich hatte ja das DSL 16.000 vorher auch.
Weil halt Telefonanschluss,
ähm, auch, also mit DSL 16.000 nicht wirklich viel billiger gewesen ist.
Dann habe ich quasi gespielt über DSL 16.000.
Also sprich, mit diesem 1 MBit Upload.
War komplett vernachlässigt, aber zum Spielen vollkommen ausreichend.
Und gestreamt habe ich über Unity Media.
Mit dem DSL 16.000.
Und mit 5 MBit Upload.
Das ist jetzt natürlich mit den 40 MBit viel besser.
Crosshair.
Kann ich dir zeigen.
Crosshair, wo ist es?
Ne, da.
Wenn es dich interessiert.
Ja.
So.
Wie, das hat nicht getroffen?
Orisa, verpiss dich.
Der Winston, ist der lebensmüde oder was?
Der Winston ist echt lebensmüde.
Ich glaub, der ist echt, geht wieder.
Ja, scheint wieder zu gehen.
Was halt echt schwierig ist, hier gerade was zu machen.
Wenn sie sich da vorne alle raten lassen.
Oh, nice.
Der Captured, der Captured.
Trägt.
Oh, die haben den Winner.
Da muss ich jetzt aufpassen.
Was ist das für ein Name, wieso?
Auf Leute, go, go.
Moment, was?
Wie ist der denn gestorben?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ha!
Oh, wie knapp.
Wir müssen sich alle mal abfarmen lassen.
Tai Elo Place.
Ja.
Oh, gut, Shatter.
Oder wie sagt einer von den, von den, von den englischen Castern immer?
Big Slam.
Ohohoho.
Okay, das, das, irgendwie mit, mit Zen klappt das sowieso richtig, wenn du die ganze Zeit alleine da stehst.
Der Rainer, geht ab.
C9, C9, real C9.
Oh, Reinhard.
Experience Tranquility.
Jetzt müsst ihr ran, Jungs, jetzt müsst ihr ran.
Alles musst du selbst machen.
Leute.
Geht halt mal ran.
Was ist denn so schwer?
Big Slam.
Hau drauf, Reinhard, hau drauf.
Oh!
Ich reload.
Das war nicht schlecht.
Ah, schön gestalled.
Oh, ordentlich was gekillt.
Dass da kein Follow-Up mehr gekommen ist, gut.
Da über alles kann man auch nicht machen.
Haha, null.
Ah, shit.
Ja, um das zu hitten, muss man es dann ein bisschen öfters wieder spielen.
Dann geht das auch.
Weil er fällt ja in einer grauen Linie.
Trifft man das eigentlich ganz gut.
Reinhard, was machst du da?
Auf, Jungs.
Haha, oh man.
Das shattert er genau da rein.
Reinhard, meine Güte, bleib da, Alter.
Ein Schuss noch.
Ein Schuss.
Nein, kein Bock.
Oh, das war...
Das war over-extended.
Äh, äh, äh, Lord...
Volk...
Volkermord.
Ähm, naja, Reinhard rasiert.
Wenn Reinhard...
Ein Lucio mit Speedboost dabei hat.
Plus...
Also, das ist das Wichtigste.
Das ist das Wichtigste, was ein Reinhard rasieren kann.
Lucio Speedboost.
Muss.
Danach gibt es natürlich noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Sowas wie eine Hanna mit Nanoboost oder sowas.
Ha!
Huge.
Hallo, ich würde dich gerne heilen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Die sterben wie die Fliegen, hey, links und rechts.
Gibt es was zum Heilen hier?
Ja.
Was?
Wie lange streamst du heute?
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Kannst du noch nichts sagen?
Warum, fragst du?
Ich würde mal.
Oh.
Okay, mehr konnte ich da jetzt nicht machen.
Leute, stall.
Stall den Scheiß.
Geht halt ran.
Ne, keine Chance.
Keine Chance.
Da geht nichts.
Aber, war ein paar ganz gute Standplays dabei.
Bam!
Sehr, sehr nice, das Teil.
Also, eher spätestens 21 Uhr ist Schluss.
Ich hoffe, das kommt jetzt nicht öfters vor,
dass das Sound so ass und krumm spackt.
So, next game.
Ich meine, es ist Sonntagabend.
Das müsste eigentlich instant gehen.
Richtig.
Ist auch kein Spiel, in dem so viel Spielen wie von 20 Millionen Spieler, von den 19 Millionen
schon aufgehört haben.
Es wäre schön, wenn Blizzard realistische Spielzahlen veröffentlichen würde, weil 20
Millionen verkaufte Spiele sagen halt nichts wirklich aus, über wie viel aktuellen Spielen.
Blizzard hätte auch viel mehr machen können, um die Leute bei Laune zu halten.
Wenn du es halt versuchst, so zweigleisig zu fahren, so quasi...
competitive leute anzusprechen ach heute ist ja montag stimmt so ist das halt
montags freiheit aber wenn man versucht beide anzusprechen weil sie kette leute
plus competitive und ist alles so halbherzig meine ränder beide weg
würdest du dich auf einen fokussieren jetzt glaube ich bessere chancen
meine ansicht der dinge das wird nichts winzen ohne ohne support
aber wir haben die war ja so wie das hier noch mal so noch
ich kann es nicht mehr ich kann es nicht mehr
danke junkrat da oben kann man draufstehen wusste gar nicht was macht
ihr denn nach vorne
es gibt so nicht dass der ausgerechnet da drin landet er meine gott leute wo
seid ihr denn alle weg die fahrer war geil oder wieder genau auf dieser einen
mine gelandet ist auf diesem einen auf dieser einen trap geht das war eine
beknackte und wusste nicht dass schon alles droht ist zwar echt bescheuert
aber mercy kill
külsen wichtigste aus dem hat kein chance zwar kacke das hat man besser
machen müssen aber deswegen habe ich ja zweiуля kommt das ist doch scheiße noch
machen kann nur dass ich andere leute des games
kakafu locken nun springt eine tür haben und jetzt stört er da oben alter
das ist ja der tat der ebio
Aber der Doomfist war geil, wie er gegen die Tür gesprungen ist.
Sogenannte Troll-Account?
Nein, das ist kein Troll-Account.
Ich habe es seit Season 4 nicht mehr gespielt, richtig.
Ich muss mich jetzt erst wieder an das Game gewöhnen.
Deswegen habe ich mir einen zweiten Account gemacht.
Oder einen dritten? Vierten?
Was weiß ich.
Ja, Sam Fischer, es ist halt so, ne?
Aber, dass da der Carry carryt, kannst du dich halt nicht drauf verlassen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Also, das ist Quickplay.
Kannst dich auf nichts verlassen.
Hallo, König Burschi.
Danke.
Nein.
Oh Mann, das gibt es doch nicht.
Das hat er sich ja auch gelassen.
Der Champion.
Das muss jetzt echt...
Schieß her, schieß her.
Du musst alles selber machen.
Alles.
Du musst alles selber machen hier gerade.
Wie ging das nochmal mit dem schnelleren Springen?
Ich kann das, ich kriege das nicht mehr gebacken gerade.
So.
Irgendwie so.
Den Bogen kriege ich schon wieder raus.
Nein.
Boah.
Man kann es ja mal probieren.
Ich bin so dumm, dass ich in diese Falle gelaufen bin.
Weil, habe ich es gesehen.
Irgendwie so, ne?
Irgendwas.
Komm her.
Jetzt wollten sie es aber wissen.
Egal.
Guck mal.
Wir haben 99% noch Zeit.
Wir könnten mal zur Abwechslung regroupen.
Sag mal, was ist denn das hier?
What the fuck?
Komm mir da jetzt mal rein.
Ich geh mit unseren Leuten mit.
Ich bin der Köpfe, du bist die Böse.
Was?
Ich war doch weg.
Das geht nicht.
Ey, das...
Na gut, es ist Quickplay.
Was erwarte ich dann auch?
Was erwarte ich dann?
Vielen Dank für den Follow.
Ich versuch die Nummer zu schließen.
Was ist das hier denn?
Ist das ein Robot?
Das kommst du dir echt verarscht vor jetzt, ne?
Was? Ich hab was unlockt?
Für was denn?
Well played?
Was?
Was hab ich denn unlockt?
Ich hab alles gegeben, naja.
Also ein paar Sachen waren schon ziemlich beknackt,
was ich gemacht hab.
Aber da konntest du nichts machen.
Das war vollkommen unmöglich.
Ja, unmöglich.
Das ist halt so das typische Rumgefiele.
Und das Schlimme ist,
dass du das teilweise
noch bis Grandmaster siehst.
Nicht so schlimm
wie in diesem Game.
Aber dieses
Reingerenne und Sterbe alleine,
das siehst du bis auf Grandmaster hoch.
Und ich finde,
das zeigt schon irgendwie,
also eines der vielen Sachen,
die zeigt das mit dem Ranking-System, was nicht stimmt.
Wenn du ein Großmeister bist,
in diesem Spiel,
da musst du verstanden haben,
wie das Spiel funktioniert.
Sonst wirst du kein Großmeister.
Und du kannst das Spiel nicht verstehen,
wenn du Mercy linksklick halten kannst
und Grandmaster wirst. Das geht nicht.
Kein Soldier.
Grünsten?
Lieber.
Naja, das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Äh, X-Flame?
Normal schon.
Aber Duo-Q ist schon,
anstrengend genug.
Obwohl es Quickplay ist.
Ansonsten, schon, ja.
So, jetzt mal wieder an die neuen
Diva-Fähigkeiten gewöhnen.
Weil die Gegner besser sind, gegen die man spielt.
Moment, Leute, wo seid ihr denn?
Ha!
Nice!
Ach, rein, mal rein, Raketen!
Ich vergesse die immer.
Die haben ja Cree, so nicht.
Ha, lol!
Oh, ne!
Ich wollte Dings klicken.
Wollte eigentlich Ulti klicken.
Hab ich aber nicht.
Ich kack genug bin.
Oh, voll in die Rakete gerannt.
Ja.
Geht doch nur um Spaß.
Naja.
Ist klar, geht jetzt um Spaß.
Geht immer so, sonst hört man das nicht spielen.
Aber permanent auf die Fresse kriegen, ist ja auch nicht so geil.
Okay, der nächste Boost geht rein.
Nächstes getroffen.
I'm on fire!
Und bald die Fahrer hier.
Wird deletet, wenn sie hier langkommt.
Moment, die ist schon durch.
Haha!
Rekt!
Boah, die Raketen sind wahnsinnig geil.
Echt gut.
Easy.
Easy clap.
Die neue, die war jetzt echt richtig gut.
Also...
Ich hab ja gedacht, als sie die Änderung angekündigt haben damals, wo ich Patchnotes...
...gelesen hab, das wird nix.
Aber jetzt, nachdem ich das erste Mal ausprobiert hab, ist die echt gut.
Was ich noch mehr machen muss, ist den hier.
Wenn du an einem vorbeifliegst, machst du immer hier noch...
...kriegst...
...gibst du dem immer noch welche mit für 30 Damage.
Der...
...nein.
Der Fabian zockt keinen.
Kein Overwatch.
Ich find's geil, wie abhängig es davon ist, wann man seinen Stream anmacht.
Jetzt, 19 Uhr 40?
Viel weniger Viewer, als vorhin, bei vorhin irgendwie 17, 17 Uhr.
Vor allem halt durch den Neustart.
Aber ganz klar, Sonntag, äh, ähm...
Sonntag...
...Montagabend, ist logisch.
Die gehen bestimmt Main.
Nein, oh, die gehen mit, die gehen mit.
Krass, die gehen mit.
Haha.
Oh oh, oh oh.
Hä?
Konnte ich ja durchschießen.
Oh nee!
Haha!
Mit dem, was mit dem Roadhog los?
Deckt!
Jawoll!
An den Nahkampf muss ich mich gewöhnen.
Spielst du noch Co...
Ey, kann nicht.
Das war links, das war links.
The Place!
Oh nee!
Haha!
Haha, Anna.
Hehehe!
Nice!
Tja Anna!
Da wusstest du nicht, wo du hin sollst, ne?!
Hehehe!
Play of the Game.
Wie lange streamst du heut noch?
Oh!
Jetzt kommt hier!
Jetzt kommt's!
Bambebe, bambabam!
Ähm, weil spätestens eins von du erschloss.
Uh!
Krasses Play of the Game.
Wahnsinn.
Puhohoo!
Uh!
Null!
79%!
0%!
79 prozent also abgegangen jetzt schreckt hallo mir aus mal das muss jetzt
sein warum zog sie nicht auf main weil der main zu hoch ist und ich seit diesen
vier nicht mehr gespielt habe und ich quasi erst mal zwanzig spiele so halb
trauen müsste nicht absichtlich ja aber einfach weil ich nicht mehr so gut bin
bis ich wieder auf dem richtigen rang bin und das will ich den leuten nicht
antun außerdem das problem ist auch auf
watch hat ja keine möglichkeit folgt sagen der top auf der wahl hat ja keine
möglichkeit zum üben was spielen wir denn jetzt eigentlich
wir haben kein schild
der main ist wie gesagt seit diesen vier gar
nichts
mehr wobei doch wir haben nichts gemacht ranking ranking matches ich
glaube glaube sie sind fünf nach zehn placement zwar 3900 oder sowas aber das
war nicht gerechtfertigt das war bloß noch weil das interne mma halt sagt
denkt immer highmaster grandmaster 1 was aber nicht mehr stimmt überhaupt nicht
mehr sieht man ja auch da sind zwar teilweise immer noch gute plays bei aber
es ist aber so gut und zu macht man jeder gute leute haben machen halt konstant
gute place
was kann das noch einmal das horse das fährt genau das für kaktus ist bestes
schild placement bestes schild place mit aller zeiten was ist das hier also wir
Ist klar, dass es Quickplay ist, aber
What the fuck?
Alter, er ist tot, der Doomfist.
Haha, der Doomfist.
Wirst du Monster Hunter spielen?
Monster Hunter ist eine Serie, die
ist nicht so meins.
Ich bin nie so richtig mit Monster Hunter warmen.
Achtung, Achtung, Huge Play.
Oh ne.
Hat so nicht funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Huge.
Bongo.
Da kommt ja gar nichts.
Da kommt ja gar nichts, Bongo-mäßig.
Oh oh.
Haha.
Oh, Leute.
Spielst du bei Viewer Games zum Spaß?
Ähm, vielleicht.
Vielleicht das nächste Mal.
Ich muss jetzt das erste Mal Richtung 25
kommen, da ich schwenk anfangen kann.
Ne, ein Vierer.
Eine Vierer-Diva-Bombe.
Das ist absichtlich kaum zu schaffen.
Da müssen, da müssen alle mithelfen.
Also, das eigene Team muss mithelfen,
vor allem die Gegner müssen mithelfen.
Das Einzige, wo sowas
geplant gut geht, ist
zum Beispiel, ähm,
ähm, diese Garten-Map.
Äh, äh, Lijiang Tower Garten.
Da über die Brücke.
Oh.
Rekt.
Richtig rekt.
Diana macht's ganz gut.
Warum killen die noch was?
Eigentlich
müssten wir das schon längst...
Ja.
Gehen wir mal oben hin.
Leute, rennt doch nicht vor!
Okay.
Sorry, Max.
Max.
Quickplay.
Das ist Quickplay.
Außerdem spielst du auch nicht gut.
So meinte ich das übrigens vorhin.
Mit diesem, man kann, man kann die, die...
die Schüsse ja schon quasi dahin lenken,
bevor man die Gegner gleich hinzieht.
Funktioniert also, wie ich schon mal das...
gedacht habe.
Ich bin immer nur noch vier Tage die Woche auf der Arbeit.
Ja, richtig.
Key Winner!
Okay, das Zeug macht mir überhaupt nichts.
Gegen Schilde.
Aber Orisa macht Spaß.
Ich glaub, wenn man da...
sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat.
Leute, Leute, wir müssen zum, zum, zum Punkt.
Point.
Point, Point, Point!
Na gut.
Hehe.
Schleicher.
Angestelltes Konter, ja.
Ja.
Das ist schon ewig her.
So.
Ähm.
Sam Fisher, ich mach nochmal eins, zwei Runden alleine.
Äh.
Lief gut.
Ich mach mal auf meinen, das da...
konzentrieren kann, dass ich das wieder halbwegs auf die Reihe krieg.
Alles.
Donation.
Äh.
Bomber97.
Du kannst auf die...
wirklich donaten möchtest, kannst du auf die Profilseite gucken.
Da ist unten ein Link.
Also quasi so einer der ersten Links auf der...
Seite.
Aber ich mach Twitch ja nicht zum Kohle abgreifen, so wirklich.
Ich werde auch kein Twitch-Affiliate oder so gedönst machen.
Das einzige, wofür ich's gerne machen würde, ist für die...
Emotes.
Ja.
Für die Emotes würd ich das gerne machen.
Und...
Subscription-Zeug ist mir eigentlich egal.
Oh, Route 66.
Eine ordentliche Map.
Was spielen wir denn?
Attack Route 66.
Die Keks-Emotes, ja.
Also Emotes...
Für die Emotes würd ich's machen.
Komm, wir probieren doch mal kurz Zarya, oder?
Wollen wir gleich Soldier probieren?
Ja, komm, wir machen doch mal Zarya.
Ähm...
Am besten ist natürlich...
Also wenn ich das machen sollte...
Dann warte ich, bis ich, wie gesagt, das Ganze mal konstanter mache.
Quasi so...
So konstant, dass es dann auch...
Immer so um die, sagen wir mal, 200 Leute sind, die zugucken.
Und...
Dann...
Dann bewerbe ich mich vielleicht.
Weil ich hab ja noch von...
Von vor ein paar Jahren noch in Kontakt...
Skype.
Da könnt ich gleich mal fragen.
Vielleicht geht's dann einfacher.
Aber ich hab's da auch gar nicht so eilig.
Ich hab mir da noch nicht viel Gedanken zu gemacht.
Warum wollen die eigentlich da raus?
Das ist doch ein Knacksaus.
met'm d Spiel gehört
hat
wo sie gehört haben
es wszystkim
est
dafür bleiben einfach versteckt
j tea
wenn eingestellt
hier gibt es halt
ruch
der Weg geht ab
e
PK HE
dergate
weitung real КРУМ
und wenn ich so langsam Leute resolution
Das gibt es doch gar nicht.
Ha, das war eine
sehr mutige Rechtsklick gerade.
Das war eine schöne Bubble.
Echt.
Hahaha.
Fuck, voll da rein.
Und jetzt spielt er wieder Overwatch.
Ja, so ist das.
Das Schöne, vor allem am Anfang
in Overwatch ist,
man kann relativ schnell
sich wieder verbessern, wenn man einfach sich anguckt,
was macht man, was ist scheiße.
Zum Beispiel sagen, wenn du guckst,
hey, scheiß Schilde, scheiß Positioning,
dann kriegst du das relativ schnell wieder hin.
Was dann richtig schwer ist, ist wieder
quasi die Master-GM-Geschichte.
Lass dich doch schilden.
Lass dich schilden.
Das Schild war zum Beispiel
total beknackt.
Hehe.
Rusche.
Wo ist der nochmal?
Gefallen.
Was macht der denn da oben?
Ich hab keine Bubble mehr.
Ich muss länger warten mit dem Schild.
Ich bin damit zu schnell.
Wisst ihr? Warum hab ich den jetzt geschildert?
Richtig stumm.
Nein.
Haha.
Der Schlimmste L.A.Craft aller Zeiten.
Ich dachte, die kommen jetzt raus.
Aber ne.
Das sind so Sachen,
wenn du dann merkst, du stehst vorne drin
und wirst nervös,
weil du nicht weißt, was du machen sollst,
dann einfach so Zeichen für
du musst nur da sein,
Du musst mehr spielen.
Dass du das nicht mehr hast.
Das habe ich gerade gemerkt mit Zarya.
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, was ich machen soll.
Und das ist schlecht.
Das sollte eigentlich nie sein.
Du solltest im besten Fall immer wissen, was du machen musst.
Und wenn du richtig gut bist,
weißt du nicht schon, was du machen musst,
sondern kannst dir sogar schon überlegen, was du als nächstes machst.
Aber da bin ich mittlerweile ganz weit weg in Overwatch.
Na, Back.
Man wollte es wissen.
Ah, ich habe gepusht.
Ja, X-Flame, das stimmt.
Das ist halt Quickplay.
Am besten ist halt, du spielst hier irgendwelche Helden,
die sich selbst so ein bisschen supporten können.
Soldier ist natürlich ganz weit vorne mit dabei.
Torb auch so ein bisschen.
So was halt.
Mein Anna geht auch.
Ha, ihr habt schon keinen Bock mehr?
Rudebox.
Mercy-Skins.
Schlimmste.
Wir sind schon Level 8.
Okay, that's auuuuh.
Daniel kommt schon runter.
Also, ich denke mal noch so 2-3 Streams,
dann sind wir 25.
In Kruppe bekommst du mehr XP, ich weiß.
Ich habe ja eben auch bis in Krupp gespielt.
esperado?
Katalley und Jeno kommen zu einem Überbrieg geeinigt.
Zexastack.
Ich will wenigstens, bis ich 25 bin,
wieder so halbwegs die Helden drin haben, die gerade angesagt sind und wieder king svсп kam.
Ab permeele auf alguma Prozesse.
Und wieder up to date sein, was Neuen Maps angeht
und neue Unfähigkeiten, Änderungen von Helden und sowas.
Ja, das muss bis 25
wieder drin sein.
2CP, wie oft soll man diesen Kack-Modus
denn heute Abend noch spielen?
Ich hasse
diesen Spielmodus. So schrecklich.
Warum hast du den Wettrat
gespielt? Na, warte mal ab, was die andere
bekommt. Torb, Torb.
Torb? Torb.
Es sei denn, wir brauchen noch einen Support.
Dann warte ich mal ab.
Mal gucken, ob einer Support pickt.
Junkrat. Oh ja, Junkrat
muss ich auch noch üben. Junkrat kann ich
gar nicht.
Äh.
Ähm.
Keine Ahnung.
Außer, oh, mit Anna wird das wieder
schrecklich werden. Die rennen alle wild
links rum, rechts rum, vorne rum,
oben, unten, hinten. Ich will jetzt wieder
keinen sehen, den heilen.
Was geht mit dem ab?
Ja, Overwatch macht am meisten Spaß mit 6er-Gruppe.
Definitiv. Definitiv.
Sniper! Sniper!
Diva! Warum?
Warum fliegst du?
Was zum Teufel?
Was zum Teufel
geht hier ab? Was kann er nicht sagen,
dass die schon alle tot sind?
Was soll ich
da supporten?
Fuck.
Ich hol grad ne Granate
auf die Füße.
Und das Schlimme ist,
wir halten das jetzt auch noch, ne?
So absolut planlos.
Komplett planlos.
Moment.
Da ist einer auf dem Punkt.
Kein Jux.
Nicht genug geheilt. Ja, offensichtlich.
Ne? Offensichtlich. Vor allem nicht mich.
Pass mal auf,
jetzt kommt hier.
Krasse Nade.
Äh.
Äh. Na.
Boah, knapp.
Wollt ihr die nicht chasen?
Boah!
Oh, mein Support macht überhaupt
keinen Spaß hier. Was ist denn da hier los?
Na, 6-Deck.
Ich muss gucken, dass ich wieder gescheit spiele,
bis 25.
What? Why?
Okay. Nein.
Ihr wollt nicht, dass ich euch sehe.
Nein.
Kein.
Was?
Oh, Mann. Fuck.
Ich hab ihn nicht gehört.
So, ich Nano-Boost jetzt irgendeinen
und wechsel dann auf irgendeinen
Random-Held, so.
Ich will jemand Nano-Boosten. Hallo.
Wo seid...
Ach, ne.
Hey, Tybilius. Ich rage nicht.
Das kann man nicht ragen nennen.
Es ist halt so planlos.
Hier kannst du nicht supporten.
Das funktioniert nicht. Bleib stehen!
So, Sontra. Go.
Ist mir scheißegal, ob da jetzt einer ist.
So.
Stop. Zen.
Eurer. So.
Es geht ja nix hier.
Was ist das?
Was? Ah ja.
Ah, links, links. Ziel. Ganz vergesst.
Neuer Held.
Oh, ne. Es ist mit Shift. Es ist links.
Hm.
Hallo, McPhee. Hallo.
Und tschüss.
Ich bin aufgedroht.
Ich bin aufgerutscht.
I'm goin'.
revelation.
Ich bin zusammen.
Caroline.
Ich bin zurück.
Beim Tellen.
ich finde gut, dass Moira mal ein bisschen
komplexerer
Support ist.
Das finde ich echt gut.
Äh.
Mehr konnte ich jetzt nicht machen.
Warum sind die nicht auf dem Punkt?
Sie sind nicht auf dem Punkt gewesen.
Bitte.
Ja, Anna ist auch komplex. Ich finde das gut.
Ich bin auch voll
überfordert.
Jetzt haben wir keinen Support mehr.
Das ist ja dumm.
Ich gehe wieder.
Ja doch, Anna zu spielen ist
sauschwer. Also gut zu spielen.
Der will sterben, glaube ich, der McCree.
Kostet er eigentlich recht? Ich kriege auch eine Anna.
Was?
Das Teil, äh.
Irgendwie
irgendwie
Irgendwie hat der Held was.
Der gefällt mir.
Gut, Rain Shield hast du halt keinen.
Ach, rechtsklick
füllt man dann wieder auf.
Äh.
Muss einem ja auch mal gesagt werden.
Verstehe.
Nein, ich wollte einen heilen.
Fuck.
Wie viel Damage? Burst-Damage macht das Ding nicht.
Jetzt der Putsch.
Recken klar alle Insta, ich sag's euch.
Also, ich glaube, Moira wird's.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wir die sehen in nächster Zeit.
Irgendwelchen Pro-Matches.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht einfach.
Also, das ist jetzt, das ist glücklicherweise nicht so,
nicht ein weiterer Monster-Button-Support wie Mercy.
Ja doch, rechtsklick hielt mich selbst,
habe ich mittlerweile mitgekriegt.
Äh.
Ja, Bitch.
Null.
Moment.
Scoped.
Ah, ich habe Ana gespielt am Anfang, genau.
Moira ist in jedem GM-Match mit dabei.
Jupp.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wenn man, wenn man.
Ich finde es aber richtig, also, ich bin der Meinung,
man sollte
die ganzen,
sagen wir mal, ein bisschen höher,
high-skilligeren Helden
nicht unbedingt immer nerven.
Ich finde, es sollte,
es sollte sich auszahlen, wenn man eben
die, die schwierigen Helden gut spielt.
Und wenn es geht, halt auch nicht nur einen davon.
Weil Overwatch ist halt einfach ein Spiel,
der es pro Held jetzt nicht,
nehmen wir mal sowas aus,
mal sowas wie Tracer, Genji aus,
das ist schon saumäßig schwer, das richtig gut zu spielen.
Aber die meisten Helden sind halt relativ simpel.
Und
das skaliert halt eher damit,
dass man eben mehrere Helden ganz gut kann,
als einen.
Einen Held richtig gut,
in Overwatch zu können, ist jetzt nicht so das Ding.
Vor allem, wenn's,
sagen wir mal so, sowas wie Mercy, finde ich,
kann ich es eh komplett vergessen.
Das, das zählt meiner Ansicht nach nicht.
Wenn ich sehe, wie viel Grandmaster Mercys
das grundlegende Spielprinzip hier nicht verstanden haben
und immer noch quasi staggern bis zum Gehtnichtmehr teilweise.
Aber es müsste mehr Helden in der Richtung geben.
Deswegen ist Moira da, finde ich, schon ein richtiger Schritt.
Und man muss sagen,
Winston, so einfach raus,
der ist nicht einfach.
Sagen übrigens auch die ganzen Koreaner.
Top 10 sind 5 Mercy-Mens.
Das kann schon sein.
Und der Rest ist Tracer, ne?
Nein!
Falsch, falsche Fähigkeit, falsche Fähigkeit.
Es ist eh Rechtsklick.
Nein!
Ich mach immer den falschen,
kack,
den falschen Spell!
Gengu.
Warum feedest du, Genji?
Hör auf! Hör auf!
Stopp!
Will, the point is mine.
You love the joint.
You seem in need of aid.
Äh...
Aber Tracer, gibt's auch sau viele GM-Tracers.
Das finde ich aber auch gut.
Also alle, die...
schreien Nerf Tracer,
ist...
blödsinnig.
Capture.
Nerf, Nerf Tracer ist blödsinnig.
Tracer ist einer der wenigen High-Skill-Chars in diesem Game.
I will take a shield generator, and...
Boah, Grille oder Kind?
Ich glaube, eher Kind.
Ups.
Wie setzt man...
Wie setzt man denn die Moira-Ult am besten ein?
Ich meine, das Ding hielt ja und macht Damage.
Wobei der Damage gefühlt jetzt nicht...
...total übertrieben ist.
Also man kann damit nichts umbürsten.
Ich glaube, das Schlimmste an der Moira-Ult für die Gegner ist, dass sie nichts sehen.
Oh ne.
Ich kann da nicht rein.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Hätte klappen können.
Zumindest...
Zumindest nen...
...nen Tick hätten wir kriegen können.
Die wollen alle nicht geheilt werden.
Da war ja kein Bock.
Wie ist eigentlich die Range so von Moira-Rechtsklick?
Ah, Mann.
Falscher.
Das ist wirklich nicht so simpel.
Jetzt habe ich den Gegner versucht zu heilen, anstatt Damage zu machen.
Alles...
Ja, Yoshi, alles gut.
Renn durch 20 Meter.
Ja, aber Moira ist so ein Charme.
Weil man den gut kann.
Ich glaube, das hat richtig aus...
Das hat vielmehr so schon...
...Impact.
Warte.
Ich habe nur ein Objektiv.
Rallye.
Oh, weg hier, weg hier, weg hier.
Du hast halt überhaupt keinen Support.
Wie geht's denn?
Immer die gleichen Fragen hier.
Grill.
Nein, kein Grill.
Kind.
So witzig aus.
Das war eine absolut nackte Ult.
Ich wusste nicht, was ich machen soll.
Zumal es hier auch überhaupt nicht vormanns geht.
Ich musste meinen Opponenten retten und michelines senken.
Ich da
Ins hourly.
Der ist nicht da.
Die Antwort ist okay.
Kann ich jetzt im血.
Der Orb ist schon krass.
Okay, die lassen sich ums Verrecken nicht heilen.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Ja.
Oh nein, oh nein, weg, weg, weg, weg.
Oh, war das knapp.
Da kam gleich das Tire an.
Kam gleich das Tire angerauscht.
So, ich denke mal, letztes Match.
Nach ihm, so ging es Erox vorhin auch.
Game gestartet, nein, kein Bock mehr.
Mal gucken, wie viel Bock ich habe, wenn ich 25 bin.
Na, auf Game.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, als es neu war,
wo du quasi auf Search gedrückt hast,
hast du quasi schon, bevor das Suchefeld oben aufgegangen ist,
hast du ein Game gefunden.
Kann man bei dir mitmachen?
Nee, ich mache jetzt letztes Game.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit einmal Duo gequeued für mehr XP.
So, mal ein, zwei Runden alleine spielen.
Zwei Minuten auf Game waren, ja, das ist krass.
Vor allem, ey, hallo?
Oh, in dem Bereich muss es massig Leute geben.
Ja, verkaufte Einheiten sagt halt nicht so viel darüber aus, wie viel wir wirklich spielen.
Ich bin immer noch der Ansicht, wenn man sich komplett auf eine Sache fokussieren würde,
also sagen wir mal zum Beispiel auf den Competitive Aspekt,
und den quasi mit gesamter Manpower ausbauen würde,
so dass es quasi keine Wünsche mehr offen bleiben
und das Game sich so ein richtig,
das ist so ein richtig guter Game,
den Ruf in der Richtung auch dann bekommt.
Das bringt,
das sollte die Spieler eigentlich am meisten halten.
Aber, ich meine, die haben selbst Leute,
die sich um sowas Gedanken machen.
Wobei man sagen muss,
naja, wenn man sich Spiele anguckt,
die Blizzard in letzter Zeit so rausgehauen hat,
also quasi,
sagen wir mal Starcraft 2, Diablo 3 und sowas,
das sind auch Sachen, die halt sehr extrem unter Spielerschwund leiden, ja.
Oder gelitten haben
und teilweise kaum noch existent sind.
Ich meine, guckt euch Starcraft 2 an.
Klar, ab und zu gibt es noch ein paar größere Turniere,
aber die kriegen dann was?
15k Zuschauer oder sowas.
Oh, wir haben einen Lucio.
Am besten die Leute, die immer sagen Lucio, der Lucio.
Der Lucio ist das.
Lucio.
Ähm,
ich meine eigentlich, ne,
kommen wir zum zweiten Support.
Ich kann nicht ein bisschen Moira üben.
Muss ich wahrscheinlich im Rank dann auch spielen.
Weil, Support Main und so, ne.
Die haben genug Geld durchs Bau, ja, das ist richtig.
Ha, gleiche Idee, hä.
Direkt.
Reinhardt, komm zurück.
Leute, kommt halt zurück.
Was machen die denn da?
Okay, den Shift muss ich mir noch angewöhnen von Moira.
Den verwende ich noch gar nicht.
Haha, der ist in den Orb gerannt.
Also, die sind wirklich mutig, hier, die Jungs.
Kommt doch mal ein bisschen zurück.
Ich höre rechts was, oder?
Habe ich rechts was gehört?
Die müssen jetzt pushen, die werden jetzt richtig hart.
Richtig hart drauf pushen.
Easy, was ist denn das für eine Runde?
Ha, der Flamer.
Wie er flamed im Chat.
Der Lucio.
Wie spricht man das eigentlich richtig aus?
Das heißt Lucio, oder?
Ja.
Weil, ich meine, der Typ, der Lucio spricht, sagt auch Lucio.
Und das ist ja Brasiliano.
Oder zumindest spricht er Portugiesisch.
Gerade hatte er ja die gleiche Idee wie ich.
Oder das meint...
Oh, Alter.
Rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf.
Achtung, Achtung.
Kommt nix.
Sag mal, die wollen es echt wissen mit Spawn-Camp, ne?
Hä?
Siehst du, so schnell kann es in die Hose gehen.
Oh, nee.
Da schreit sie, heal me.
Speed, please.
Wadum, wadum, wadum.
War ein bisschen mit dem Voice-Chat rumnervt.
Ich verliere meine Wille.
Ähm...
Echt?
Ich verliere meine Wille.
Wenigstens muss er mit Moira jetzt ein bisschen auf die Gegner zielen.
Drop the beat.
Ich verliere meine Wille.
Das war die erwartete Schlussfolgerung.
Echt?
So muss das sein.
Alter, ich hab alles Gold.
Hahaha.
Lol.
Ja, mein Schiff vergesse ich zu oft.
Easy clap.
Alles Gold.
Nicht, dass es irgendwas aussagen würde.
Rekt hat gereckt.
Ja.
Edward, eindeutig MVP.
Was wollen sie hier?
Walking Dead.
Watt.
Aber Moira macht Bock.
Und ich glaube, wenn man wirklich...
...sich da mal reinge...
...gedacht hat, wie das funktioniert und da auch mal ein paar ordentliche Spielschuhe schon drauf hat,
dann rapest du damit alles weg.
Sowohl Damage-mäßig, kriegst sauschnell deine Ulti, kannst ziemlich gut heilen.
Wenn du eine gute Balance hast zwischen Damage und Linksklick, hast du auch immer Mana.
Das sieht mir ziemlich OP aus.
Und diese Kugel hat einen ziemlich großen Radius und bouncet auch total oft.
Übrigens, ich muss sagen, Moira ist das erste Charakterdesign, was mir...
...gar nicht gefällt in Overwatch.
Sonst, jeder Charakter finde ich irgendwie cool, ja.
Moira finde ich...
...irgendwie dumm.
Huuuuh.
Ah, oh, da spielt einer Moira, das ist schön, da kann ich jetzt mal was anderes spielen.
Gucken wir mal, was die Leute wählen.
Der Kugelnerv nicht live geht...
...also, dass die Kugel vielleicht ein bisschen kleineren Radius kriegt oder weniger...
...oft bounce...
...scheint mir...
...gerechtfertigt zu sein.
Aber ich hoffe halt, dass...
...ich meine, Moira ist offensichtlich...
...ein Charakter...
...siehst du allein schon danach, wie viele Fähigkeiten die hat...
...und, wie gesagt, ich spiele sie heute auch erst zum ersten Mal...
...den ich eindeutig zu einem bisschen, bisschen höheren Skill...
...zu ein bisschen höheren Skillklasse zählen würde.
Und es wäre blöd, wenn quasi ausgerechnet so ein Held wieder direkt genervt wird.
Es braucht mehr Helden.
Es braucht, es braucht mehr Helden, sowas in der Richtung.
Doomfist, Genji, McCree, Top, Pharah...
...ist, kann auch, ist auch kein Ding.
Aber easy.
Soldier, gut zu spielen, auch nicht allzu einfach.
Äh, Sombra...
...weiß nicht.
Tracer, richtig gut.
Ähm, auch schwer zu spielen, finde ich auch.
Guter, guter Held, passt wunderbar.
Bastion, naja gut, Bastion halt.
Hanzo, ziemlich inkonsistent.
Äh, Junkrat, absolut OP.
Äh, Mei...
...naja, Top.
Situationsbedingt, D.Va OP.
Orisa, auch ziemlich gut. Reinhardt, gerade nicht so tolle.
Winston, richtig gut.
Ähm, also es gibt ein paar Helden...
Warte mal, wir müssen jetzt erstmal picken.
Also...
Oh, geht da gleich mal einer geliefen.
Was ist das hier?
So, wisst ihr was?
E, E, Max, du vergisst immer dein E.
Schon ist er tot, der Reinhardt.
Äh, hallo?
Wo ist denn die Widow?
Ist die hier noch irgendwo?
Hehe, voll ins Mehle reingerannt.
Eax, Eax, stimmt nicht.
Vier.
Vier, der Vierte ist das.
Ich wollte für den Stream einmachen.
Und aber ganz von vorne.
Fuck, das war...
...Overextension of Doom.
Heal?
Haben wir überhaupt Heal?
Nein, Hanzo!
Oh, oh, renn in mich rein, ey.
Spast, McCree, ey.
Wir...
Moment!
Heißt unser McCree...
Ne, heißt unsere Tracer allen Ernstes Gebärmutter?
Hahaha!
Aha!
Geb...
Oh Mann!
Was ein scheiß Name!
Mann, warum nennt man sich Gebärmutter?
Weg!
Oh, da schießen wir.
Achtung, Achtung, Leute!
Huge, Huge!
Huge!
Wat?
Easy!
So muss das sein.
Hallo, Mr. Toonie.
Also, wenn die Games so schnell gehen...
Sollen wir noch ein Game machen?
Hab's ja gesagt, eins waren schon Schluss, aber mal...
Jaa...
So, jetzt.
Jetzt, ich hab's ja gesagt.
Eins war schon Schluss.
Ja...
So, jetzt.
Jetzt, ich muss hier.
Ich habe den Schuss auf!
Ah.
Vergiss nicht deine Raketen.
Ja, da muss ich mich noch, da muss ich echt dran denken.
Gewehrmutter.
Boah.
Mächtige 26%.
Aber die war spray.
Übrigens, sagen wir an die ganzen Follows heute wieder.
Tanku, Schleicham,
Chestos Maximus, Pazzi,
Smenia 98,
Romk, Bappe,
Derwinky,
Marso,
Skillkeule, Dermnik,
Bello 28. Mehr seh ich nicht.
Ah, Ranked ist es in O.W.
Toxic des Todes.
Ja, Eax kann schon sein.
Wenn sie Ranked mal wenigstens gescheit machen würden.
Hey.
Wollen wir mal voll fottem
King of the Hillside
abspielen?
Ja.
Ja, fangen wir mal an.
Ich mach ein bisschen auf jeden Fall.
So.
Okay.
Wenn ich da noch mal etwas reine
Schlachtreife mit mir drauf habe,
ich trage das mal da rein.
Ich glaube, es wird ziemlich gut.
Ich habe noch keine Ahnung.
Wem schiebt man das eigentlich?
Seine Schilder sind voll zittert.
Oh.
Da kann ich kein Geld mehr anziehen,
wenn wir mal was haben.
Also, ja.
Ich habe immer, ich habe immer eine
große Angst vor meinen Freunden.
Was, die wollen, dass wir
die zwischen uns verursachen?
Ich meine, wenn Deutschland
das nicht so gut macht,
dann sind sie mir nicht gut.
Ja, ich gebe ihm nicht die ganze Zeit.
Ich kann die ganze Zeit nicht.